des files qui se lit qui centre nous
arlette vermeren les faits elle même et
les transforment en oeuvre l'amour des
fils est un virus qu'elle a attrapé je
l' ai toujours eu pourquoi parce que
j'avais une mère qui faisait de la haute
couture
g
mon enfant a baigné dans les tissus donc
je pense que j'ai pris ce virus et j'ai
toujours été passionné tout d'un coup je
suis parti en récupérant tout ce qui me
tombait sous la main et de petites
choses je suis arrivé je travaille comme
vous voyez vraiment des très grandes
heures des oeuvres monumentales par
scarlett vers murray n'aime pas
travailler petits mais aussi des pièces
plus discrètes ou l'artiste joue sur le
tissu vestimentaire un textile parfois
futuristes comme ceux de cette jeune
designer et ses t-shirts brodé avec des
fils conducteurs
je travaille sur l'aspect génératif du
coup du vêtement donc le l'interaction
n'a pas de fonction en fait ici dans le
dans le projet il n'a que pour but de
montrer en fait une esthétique le
le concept aussi c'est de travailler sur
du court un artisanat numérique donc
vraiment l'intégration en fait de
l'électronique de manière du manuel
hydrophobe anti-ondes antipollution le
vêtement se décline sous plusieurs
formes des pièces que l'on pourrait
porter dans un avenir proche